Paul Joseph Watson is an author in the
editor-at-large of infowars.com and
prison planet comm Paul welcome to the
Rubin report hi Dave good to be here
glad you are here when we were talking
before we started you were saying that
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get some hate
for this are you warning me of pre hate
I think you've probably already got some
hate just for announcing that I'm gonna
be on I mean there's a lot of people who
have some kind of bought her over
you know Infowars and alex jones they
think is you know just conspiracy
central but most people don't realize
that you know alex is not this big main
controlling force that is like dictating
what everybody says you pretty much
gives me free rein to talk about
whatever I want and that's what's good
about Infowars it's a very broad church
so you've got you know numerous writers
commentators who work with him for wars
and they both can basically talk about
and write about whatever they want so as
far as I'm concerned that's the best job
imaginable so I think people need to get
over it and move on because the issues
that we're talking about supersede any
perception about what Infowars is about
what people think it's about so you know
I just want people to listen to what
I've got to say and concentrate on the
issues rather than you know what website
is hosted on that's irrelevant at the
end of the day right and that's exactly
what happened I mean I just sent one
tweet out this morning saying that you
were coming on the show and immediate ah
conspiracy theorist he works with Alex
Jones and it's like you guys are having
conspiracy theories about the conspiracy
theory so I was like you know let's just
talk it out and we'll see what happens
right no it's it's not as bad as it used
to be I mean I know there's this
perception out there that you know
Infowars is discredited or whatever but
I mean we're breaking stuff every day
we're linked on the Drudge Report
you know we've got 20 million listeners
a week now for the radio show so whether
you like it or not we're a presence and
you know that's why some people have a
problem with it as I said just
concentrate on the issues of what I'm
saying
and in fact my youtube channel explores
these kind of issues off on a tangent
from the normal content that Infowars
would cover so I've kind of
to the new satellite audience outside of
Infowars so it's all about bringing new
people in and that's why I've attempted
to do that's why I think I've been
successful recently
yeah and it's your YouTube channel that
actually got me familiar with what you
were doing because you did a phenomenal
video on the regressive left which
everyone knows I'm not a fan of them
you've done some really interesting
stuff about the European immigration
crisis so yeah we're going to get into
all the issues stuff but just to wrap up
the the Infowars part of this how did
you get involved with Infowars what's
your relationship like with Alex let's
go down that route for a little bit well
I mean I start my own political website
when I was about 18 years old so you
know I would go home and host a radio
show on dial-up internet to three people
to three listeners you know back in the
early 2000s so that was the very genesis
of Alex liked what he was doing he liked
the content I was covering so he
basically had hunted me and said you
know coming in coming at Infowars coming
right for us and that's that's what
happened so now I'm based in London
they're based in Austin Texas so I'm up
you know six hours ahead of time so I
can get a jump on the news that's always
beneficial with the news organization
sure so that's why it kind of works and
he lets me write and say what I want
he's not this controlling presence and
you know a lot of people think that Alex
Jones is a kind of act that it's put on
this radio personality that he has but
if you meet him any hanging around with
him what you see is what you get that's
Alex Jones he's like that all the time
it's not an act he's not putting it on
you know in private in person he's kind
of more jovial and fun than his rants on
the radio would suggest but that's him
that's his personality it's not an act
yeah I'm curious were you trepidatious
to join forces with him because
obviously it was a good opportunity and
saying that it's worked for you but
because of what I said before about I
just send one tweet out and people start
yelling at me you must have had some
level of concern right well that was
that was a long time ago back in the day
so really Alex was only a few years into
his operation true I mean I built up at
a good deal of traffic with my own
website so there was no
predation it was just about reaching a
wider audience so obviously I jumped at
the opportunity yeah so where do you
actually consider yourself politically I
think I have a good sense and one of the
things we've been talking about here is
sort of this new growing center people
who really want to stand up for free
speech and civil liberties but also
understand that we have real threats and
that this immigration issue in Europe is
a big problem they want to be able to
honestly talk about Islamism so the old
dynamic of right/left Democrat
conservative for us in the States it all
seems to be crumbling so I'm curious
what do you even consider yourself if
you had to go at the label um while I
grew obviously when I was a teenager I
was a progressive and I think it was
Winston Churchill that said if you're
not a liberal when you're young you have
no heart if you're not conservative when
you get older you have no brain Roe at
the moment in my 30s I would consider
myself mainly a libertarian maybe you
could call me a conservator Ian but it's
somewhere within that gap between the
two so that's basically where I'm at
right now yeah do you find that movement
growing where you are because I do sense
it's growing here you know our politics
have gotten so crazy between a
Democratic Socialist who's the hot guy
on the left and Trump who's sort of off
the rails but confute you know it is he
really a Republican does he really stand
for conservative values or is he truly a
centrist none of it makes sense anymore
are you guys getting some of that
feeling - um to some extent yeah but I
mean in the UK it's still extremely
left-wing I mean even even the Tory
party isn't classically conservative
they're somewhat left on a lot of issues
so most people don't even know what a
libertarian is in the UK to be honest
only people who are really politically
active will know what that actually
means so I think America is streets
ahead in the sense of actually
understanding that there is a political
alternative outside of progressivism
which is still what dominates the entire
discourse in the UK I mean people will
think you're racist or a bigger if if
you're not progressives especially as a
young person yeah so the circles in
which I move there's very little
understand
about what these labels even mean which
is why I tried to concentrate on the
issues without you know coming at it
from a left or right persuasion yeah and
that's very much what I tried to do and
I've tried to define a lot of these
terms and you know the whole libertarian
ideology really fits with me you know
anything like do with your body what you
want let the government stay out of your
life for the most part and build a life
that works for you but you're saying
that that the idea of that is really
gone in the UK now I don't think I don't
think it was ever here really I don't
think people came to grips with it yeah
I mean there's still there's still some
debate within libertarian circles about
certain issues like abortion or like
open borders I mean some libertarians
think that to be truly classically
libertarian you have to advocate open
borders other people say well no that's
the government foisting open borders
upon the people you know taking their
tax money to pay for it but I mean
within the UK as far as I'm concerned in
my experience these these labels aren't
even known they're not even defined so
when you describe yourself as a
libertarian people have no frame of
reference so they think if you're not a
liberal then you must be on some obscure
fringe of the political spectrum but you
know I guess that the understanding is
growing especially with the backlash
against social justice warriors which is
really accelerated in the past 18 months
so now these issues are beginning to be
brought to the fore now people are
beginning to understand that
libertarianism is a backlash against
authoritarianism which of course is
embodied by this feminist third wave
feminist social justice warrior Minh
yeah you're you're hitting all the buzz
words there so do you think it's really
like just a branding issue for
libertarians because there's sort of no
unifying principle that's bringing us
together other than do what you'd like
and don't harm someone so they just need
sort of better there are good reps
basically or at least from what I see in
the United States we have a couple Gary
Johnson former governor of New Mexico
had on the show and he's running for
president but it's hard to gain traction
when you're one of the outsiders yeah I
think the problem
with libertarianism is there not on the
frontier of political discourse so when
you get major issues that crop up in the
news media obviously as somebody who's
politically active you have to seize
upon them and tell your story and try
and control change that narrative as
best you see fit but libertarians tend
to get stuck in the weeds you know
they're always arguing with each other
about these my new shirt issues and
they're not really on the frontier of
the cultural discourse which is more you
know now the domain of of conservatory
ins and people who oppose social justice
warriors so I think in America the
libertarian movement is still so stuck
in the weeds and arguing you know my new
ship between themselves that they're not
really a robust force as they could be I
think that's one region in which they
could improve by you know hijacking
these key issues these core issues like
the migrant crisis and they're not doing
that they're they're debating with each
other over you know what Minik ism is
and whether we should have no government
or limited government and they have
speeches and three-hour u-tube
conversations about that and they're not
really reaching anyone outside their
inner circle so I think that's how you
know libertarianism needs to improve in
that way right so I guess the the silver
lining to all of this is that because of
the social justice warrior thing and now
we can get into some of these issues is
they're starting to push people into
this idea of libertarianism which is
nice so let's let's go to the social
justice warrior stuff you are not a fan
of the social justice warrior movement
to put it mildly when when did you wake
up to it when did you really see it as
as a threat to free speech I think is
probably mid 2014 I mean I was I was
mainly covering geopolitical issues back
in 2012-2013 I was mainly on you know
the Syrian civil war the build up the
arms race that the confrontation with
Russia over the course of 2013 to 2014
and then I became more active on Twitter
and it's only when you become act
on Twitter and you have to actually put
some time into it and follow the
discourse that's taking place on Twitter
that you realize that these issues are
important because it's no longer just
you know demented 14 year olds on tumblr
expressing their bizarre arcane
grievances these people are in the
Universities they are our future thought
leaders they're being coddled they're
being protected by professors at these
major universities so it was that
connection between realizing that this
is not just idiots with an opinion on
Twitter which is completely obscure this
is now a really robust driving narrative
with it amongst Millennials and that's
once you realize that once you realize
how it's how it's you know infested the
core of the education system in America
and now in Britain as well that to me
really symbolized how important it was
to oppose these people because they
oppose everything I stand for you know
within the tenets of libertarianism
itself yeah you know it's interesting
because I had very similar probably
around the same time
awakening about this because it was a
lot on Twitter right because you're
seeing this stuff on Twitter and you see
the you know the stuff from tumblr that
makes its way over and all these people
fighting about this stuff now we hear
about the trigger warnings and the safe
spaces and all this stuff but I could
never really figure out how much of this
just existed for people behind computers
but basically what you're saying is that
there's been this has been a long time
coming and that's what sort of has
seeped into the university space right
right and now it's becoming really
physical I mean you've seen the Bernie
Sanders people and we're going to get
into the whole Trump thing later but
we've sent our reporters out to
Wisconsin this past week for example and
you know it's not just Bernie Sanders
supporters it's leftists in general
they're the most vile hateful people you
could ever wish to me I mean the sheer
hatred that they give you they radiates
from their eyes when you so much as
disagree with them is palpable and now
they're out there they're shutting down
these private functions these Donald
Trump events which
whether you agree with Trump or not
that's not your free speech First
Amendment right to shut down a private
function you're impinging on other
people's First Amendment by doing that
and these people wave signs saying you
know oppose hatred oppose bigotry
they're the most hateful people you
could imagine so that's what I see now
the translation from Twitter now they're
getting out on the streets of course
we've seen that with black lives matter
that metastasized into a similar hateful
violent movement and we might get into
that later but yet it's it's manifesting
physically now and it's why people are
worried about civil unrest and riots
quite frankly because these people are
prone to violence and they're very
hateful people so okay so we're going to
get into all of that so but you hit on a
lot of things there so one of the things
that I've been saying is I can't believe
we're at a place in 2016 in America
where I fear that it will be us
ourselves the citizens who will take
away our right to free speech more than
the government so in other words it's
not a First Amendment issue in these
people protest because it's not the
government doing it but we do have a
certain social contract that you have to
let people speak and then you can use
their your speech to counteract it but
basically you're saying by blocking
roads and by stopping people from
speaking that that's where it becomes a
free speech issue not necessary right
you see that distinction no I've got no
problem with people being out on the
street protesting I mean that's their
rights when they actually go into Donald
Trump events in private buildings where
they've paid to hire this building and
they get the event in Chicago Council
for example that's impinging on other
Pitt other people's rights to peaceably
assemble exercise their First Amendment
and just listen to somebody speech but I
mean as you touched on before it's this
whole idea of you know before the power
was in the media and we're going to talk
about the media later now it's it's kind
of divested back into the hands of
people it's people power but it's people
power gone mad so now you have organized
groups of people who go out to publicly
shame others to get them fired to censor
content from the
Internet and that's how Twitter in one
sense empowered the people but it gave
that power to these perpetually outraged
mobs and that's what woke me up to the
social justice warrior issue because as
he said it the concern for me a few
years ago was the state the government
impinging on our free speech rights
now it's perpetually professionally
outraged mobs impinging on our free
speech rights I think that's the bigger
danger right now in 2016
yeah I mean listen to anything that the
state's gonna do I completely agree it's
so ironic I can't even think of an
example right now in America where the
state is holding the First Amendment
hostage I can't find one instance where
you can't say whatever you want about
the government or about government
officials or anything like that but I
can see many instances where the mob and
the online mob and they'll try to stop
your patreon funding if you're a
youtuber or they'll try to figure out
other ways to have you fired or shamed
or whatever else do you think that these
people like for example when Trump was
doing the rally in Arizona and and they
blocked the road in Arizona do you think
that they thought that they were helping
their cause because I get it that not
all of these people are thinking all
their moves through properly and they
know they're going out we're going to
stop them from showing up and that's all
good but to me all they really do is
strengthen Trump because then look
nobody that didn't get there is suddenly
not going to vote for Trump it makes
them wanted vote for Trump more and
everyone watching it on the news is
going wow who's being oppressed here
it's actually Trump so it's really it's
fascinating right now I mean I don't
know if they've got any idea of how
ridiculous they look but they've got
this media narrative backing them up
which is that Trump is inciting violence
and this is something that I've been hot
on again I don't agree with Trump on
everything I'm not a vehement trump
supporter but if you go on Twitter on
any single day and search for
assassinate Trump or kill Trump you will
find hundreds and hundreds of examples
obviously most people don't mean it
they're not going to do anything but
they're threatening to assassinate Trump
and yet the whole media narrative is
about how Trump supporters of violent
about how Trump himself is inciting
violence there's a rap video on YouTube
right now and we complain about you know
Twitter censoring conservatives for
having the wrong political opinion
there's a guy who's still on Twitter his
account hasn't been touched by the trust
and Safety Council he's got a YouTube
video which calls for caving Trump's
head in with a shovel shooting him with
an ak-47 filling him full of bullets
it's not even age restricted on YouTube
I mean I've had videos age-restricted
for swear words right and the media came
out afterwards this is a rap video
however I think it's out of Baltimore
and billboard.com celebrated it as quote
a powerful protest song this is a group
of young men in a rap video threatening
to kill Donald Trump imagine if no the
Oregon militia or whoever had come out
with a video threatening to assassinate
Hillary Clinton do you think the media
would be celebrating it as a powerful
protest song so it's that double
standard they're given left media cover
because we've got this narrative that
Trump's inciting violence when again
they're the most hateful violent people
out there
you